released to celebrate the 20th
anniversary of Nintendo's original
Pokemon game Pokemon Go has become an
instant sensation more than 15 million
people downloaded the free game in its
first week with more active daily users
than Twitter Facebook and snapchat let's
look behind what's already one of the
most popular smartphone games around
Google Earth origins Pokemon go combines
online gaming with GPS linked map
technology and both of those
technologies were pioneered by this same
man back in 1996 21 year old John Hanke
created Meridian 59 the first massively
multiplayer online game where gamers
could connect globally over the internet
to explore the game's world and compete
against one another in 2000 Hankey
developed keyhole a system linking roads
and highways with aerial photography to
create the first ever GPS linked 3d map
of the world Hankey later sold keyhole
to Google where it became Google Earth
Hankey went on to spearhead Google Maps
and Google Street View inspired by a
joke each April Fool's Day Google pulls
light-hearted pranks on its users in
2014 they announced the Google Maps
Pokemon challenge we prepared the most
rigorous test known to man to find the
world's best Pokemon master
teaming up with the Pokemon company and
Nintendo the program was a fake game
that supposedly allowed users to capture
Pokemon creatures hidden in the real
world that they could find with Google
Maps so many people desperately wanted
it to be real that the prank went viral
and just two years later the basic
concept became Pokemon go ingress - with
funding from Google hanky launched
Niantic labs in 2010 to add a gaming
layer to maps there he created a game
called ingress the first MMO that
involved the use of gamers real-world
locations it was basically Pokemon go
except without the Pokemon the most
popular user-generated meeting points in
ingress later became the poki stops and
gyms in Pokemon go Pokemon go became
available for Android and iPhone users
in North America Australia and New
Zealand on July 6 2016 it hit Europe and
most of Asia on July 15 that nine-day
gap was too much for some who downloaded
the bootleg or knockoff versions of
Pokemon go in fact at least 43 separate
fake versions of Pokemon go have been
spotted many of which are malicious apps
that flood uses phones with ads and
malware worse some of these bootlegs
could take control of the users phone
without their knowledge mining their
personal data the Hunter has become the
hunted
been in saudi-arabia Pokemon go was
gaining popularity in the Middle East
and clerics in Saudi Arabia are
skeptical to say the least
they've issued a fatwa or Islamic
religious ban on the game which follows
up a previous fatwa against the original
Pokemon games from 1996 according to
them the games trading card aspect
encouraged blasphemy and gambling while
Pokemon go might not use cards it does
apparently contain forbidden images like
symbols that could be mistaken for
Masonic symbolism in other words
Jigglypuff is the devil's
get up and move or diet while the game
helps people get more exercise as they
walk around searching for Pokemon
some still prefer their video games to
be less dangerous actually two people in
San Diego fell off a cliff while playing
the game crafty entrepreneurs in cities
like New York San Francisco and Portland
have placed ads on Craigslist offering
to drive players around while they pokey
hunt some drivers even promised to
provide the one thing coveted by players
even more than a legendary new foreign
charges thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which Pokemon you've caught today